[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti che emozione essere
qui a te rics il mio comportamento che
sta manifestando in questo momento
esprime un pochino e di ansia un pochino
di agitazione ed è questo comportamento
ondulatorio che probabilmente vedrete in
diversi speaker tranne quelli
particolarmente abituati a chiacchierare
in pubblico ed è un comportamento che
aiuta un pochino a ridurre la tensione
quello che si può vedere in un papa in
sala d'attesa mentre sto aspettando il
proprio bimbo se siamo seduti ad
aspettare un appuntamento con la gamba
che si muove in questo modo sono tutti i
comportamenti che aiutano un pochino a
gestire quelle che sono le situazioni di
ansia questo lo si riscontra anche negli
animali
se i comportamenti vengono manifestati
per troppo tempo e diventano però
comportamenti che si definiscono
patologici
io sono una psicobiologo mi occupo di
studiare il comportamento animale con un
obiettivo preciso che è quello di
garantire il benessere degli animali
all'interno di istituzioni geologiche
perché se poi il progetto legato ad
apportare la conservazione in situ di
questi animali perché noi studiamo gli
animali e perché il fatto di osservare
il comportamento animale
a volte ci porta a pensare all'uomo
perché spesso l'uomo si definisce quella
specie che è diversa da tutte le altre
specie animali e per carità da un punto
di vista di definizioni di specie noi
siamo diversi siamo diverse dal lupo e
siamo diverse dall'orso così come loro
se lo possono diversi dal la specie
umana
però è proprio vero che quelle
caratteristiche peculiari che abbiamo
studiato e osservato nell'uomo sono
effettivamente tipiche della specie
umana in particolare la preferenza
manuale
adesso facciamo una carrellata di esempi
di quelli che possono essere i
comportamenti presenti nell'uomo e che
in un certo qual modo osservare il
comportamento animale può anche
spiegarci perché vengono manifestati
ritrovando la preferenza manuale si dice
che la popolazione umana usa
principalmente la mano destra adesso non
chiederò a voi di alzare la mano tanto
quanto siete mancini ma questo studio
questi studi recenti sugli animali
dimostrano qualcosa di diverso
dimostrano che gli animali nei compiti
che vengono definiti spontanee usano sia
la mano destra che la mano sinistra ma
se voi ci pensate in un mondo che un
mondo perfettamente asimmetrico
io devo poter rispondere a tutti gli
stimoli che sono sia a destra che a
sinistra se sono seduto ad una tavola è
un amico e sulla destra che mi chiede di
passare avuti a dell'acqua
certo non faccio così per passare la
bottiglia
acqua ma nuovo prendo la mano a sinistra
e posso la bottiglia dell'acqua sulla
destra e poi la passo al mio amico che
si trova la mia destra
questo per dirvi che effettivamente ci
sono poi dei compiti con i quali noi
usiamo e principalmente lavoriamo con la
mano destra ma sostanzialmente se
dobbiamo vivere in un mondo
completamente asimmetrico c'è la
possibilità di usare entrambe le mani
perché da un punto di vista evolutivo è
più adattativo
e perché lo studio della banda estra è
così importante nella specie umana così
come negli animali perché sembra essere
legato al linguaggio e per il controllo
motorio degli archi si dice che c'è il
controllo controlaterale l'emisfero
sinistro controllo alla mano destra
l'emisfero destro controlla una mano
sinistra
tutti noi sappiamo che il linguaggio per
la maggior parte della sua produzione
recepimento è collocato la funzionalità
e quello carta nella nelle aree sinistre
dei nostri due miss veri quindi quello
che sostanzialmente si pensa ci sono co
evoluzione del linguaggio della
preferenza manuale ma è proprio vero che
il linguaggio è una caratteristica
peculiare della specie umana ed è il
linguaggio per forza di cose una
caratteristica per quella della stessa
umana siamo in grado di parlare di
emettere suoni sul tour organizzate
pensieri gli studi ci dicono che anche
gli animali iniziano ad avere utili
animali iniziano gli scienziati sono in
grado di recepire delle informazioni
dagli animali e dire che effettivamente
anche il linguaggio degli animali a
lungo raggio strutturato non solo
l'emissione di suoni casuali seguono
delle regole matematiche quindi possiamo
parlare di linguaggio negli animali come
ad esempio leggera da e nei libri sono
delle proscenio quindi ben lontani dagli
esseri umani ma quando si parla di
linguaggio si parla di comunicazione e
quindi la comunicazione fatta con
diversi canali diverse modalità quindi
abbiamo il linguaggio parlato abbiamo
l'espressione facciale
abbiamo la postura che ci spiega e dice
determinate cose quando incontriamo
delle persone sarà capitato credo a
tutti voi almeno una volta che andare ad
una cena ad una festa di cotana persona
che proprio non volevate assolutamente
vedere in quel momento
cosa succede la salutiamo intavoliamo
anche un discorso in maniera educata ma
il nostro corpo quello che dice è
completamente diverso quindi mentre
stiamo dicendo che bello come sono
contenta di vederti ma come stai
come va la tua vita oggi
l'espressione facciale con il sorriso
teso la postura che crea questa distanza
tra noi e l'altra persona dice
esattamente qualcosa di diverso perché è
così importante perché gli animali
devono comunicare un messaggio univoco
quindi la vocalizzazione l'espressione
facciale la postura devono convogliare
in un unico messaggio chiaro e preciso
perché potrebbe andar né dell'esistenza
dell'individuo stesso quindi l'essere
umano riesce a lavorare su alcune cose
ma quando si tratta di posture spessori
facciali fa un pochino più fatica a
gestire quelle che sono le emozioni e
che trasmette come comunicazione alle
altre persone quello che potete vedere
quante cazzate
certo che sì si trova si trova la forza
dell'uno verso l'altro
ma l'espressione facciale la bocca
aperta con 20 coperti che si chiama the
line senza una pasta molto chiaro nel
sessione fattuale chiara ma non soltanto
tra i due individui è importante anche
per gli altri membri del gruppo perché
qualcuno potrebbe andare in supporto
dell'uno e dell'altro è diviso quindi i
due dicono anche guardandosi attorno
guardate che stiamo giocando
non c'è nessun problema non c'è nessun
pericolo ma veniamo al bellissimo pavone
e alla coda del pavone
noi utilizziamo un termine che è
pavoneggiarsi lo usiamo anche un po con
connotazione negativa non con aspetti
così tanto positivi il pavone spreca
tanta energia nel momento in cui deve
fare questa bellissima ruota ma perché
più bella è la ruota più grande è la
ruota più tempo tiene sulla ruota e più
belli sono i colori più l'individuo è
sta dicendo sono un individuo sano sono
individuo che può garantire che la prole
sarà una prole sana e questo per la
femmina estremamente importante perché
può scegliere quell'individuo piuttosto
che un altro individuo senza banalizzare
video un pochino cosa succede negli
umani
allo stesso modo quando noi guardiamo
gli individui come prima impatto poi c'è
l'approfondimento c'è la conoscenza ma
inizialmente un bel fisico una bella
macchina bel vestito la bella casa un
conto in banca cospicuo questa serie c
si arriva dopo ma sostanzialmente perché
queste sono caratteristiche che possono
portare a delle scelte portano a delle
scelte perché queste caratteristiche
possono apparentemente garantire la
possibilità di una prole sicura della
possibilità di una garanzia quindi la
scelta viene fatta in campo e teologico
e biologico considerando quello che sarà
poi la successiva crescita e
allevamento poi della prole
altre caratteristiche che abbiamo negli
animali e che ci spiega un pochino il
comportamento degli umani l'innovazione
l'innovazione una caratteristica è un
scusate un processo particolarmente
importante nelle specie compreso l'uomo
perché ci dà la possibilità di adattarsi
sensazioni nuovi e di non estinguerci
caratteristica estremamente importante
possibilità di innovare di avere
comportamenti nuovi di sperimentare cosa
hanno fatto i ricercatori si sono
chiesti ma quali sono gli individui
all'interno di una colonia che possono
innovare
l'individuo che sono in grado di
innovare interno di una colonia sono
individui dominanti sono individui
esperti no ma perché semplicemente
perché gli individui dominanti esperti
hanno la possibilità di avere tutto ciò
di cui hanno bisogno
sono gli individui che non devono
sperimentare per ottenere qualcosa di
nuovo gli individui di basso rango gli
individui che sono ai margini un pochino
della società gli individui restano
isolati sono gli individui che per
accedere alle risorse devono ingegnarsi
devono poter sperimentare quindi
individui giovani sono in grado di
manifestare nuovi comportamenti anche
l'utilizzo di utensili è assolutamente
un nuovo comportamento che viene
utilizzato è manifestato dagli individui
questa particolare caratteristica
l'innovazione edipresse ci spiega
tantissimo ciò che avviene in campo
umano le scoperte le innovazioni
normalmente sono fatte da persone che ne
fino al giorno prima non conoscevamo
molte volte sono addirittura
riconosciute quando l'individuo quando
essere umano è già morto ma al di là di
questo sostanzialmente perché è
importante un aspetto fondamentale se
l'individuo che ai margini della società
fa una scoperta a cosa serve poi alla
società questa scoperta se l'individuo a
un individuo come aveva detto
subordinato in realtà arriva quello che
è il comportamento fondamentale è che l
osservazione quindi l'apprendimento
diventa fondamentale attraverso
l'osservazione perché l'attenzione e la
popolarità nel caso umano che viene data
poi all'individuo che ha fatto la
scoperta pone l'attenzione su quell
individuo in modo tale che questa novità
questa scoperta possa essere diffusa a
tutta l'intera popolazione con quella
che viene definita essere la
trasmissione orizzontale quindi tutti
gli individui che sono presenti
all'interno del gruppo familiare
all'interno
dopo sociali hanno la capacità di
manifestare questo comportamento
particolarmente importante è
l'apprendimento quando diventa a
prendere per sopravvivere quando è
necessario per la sopravvivenza cui vi
racconto una storia che ha una storia in
campo animale l'ibis eremita è una
specie che sorvolava più di 400 anni fa
i cieli europei cieli italiani
questa specie purtroppo e si è estinta a
causa dell'impatto antropico a causa
della caccia a causa sostanzialmente
dell'uomo però questa volta è l'uomo che
prova a rimediare che però a fare
qualcosa di particolare un'idea bizzarra
di johannes fritz così si chiama questo
ricercatore che arrivò al parco natura
viva nel 2004 e chiese aldo travesa nidi
che il direttore scientifico di questa
struttura di sostenere una sua idea da
cederà quella di allevare dei piccoli
l'ibis eremita fare in modo che questi
di questi individui
dopo tre giorni dalla schiusa venissero
elevate da mamme surrogate mamma
surrogato e cosa vuol dire vuol dire
delle mamme che non sono le mamme
naturali un termine bruttissimo ma
sostanzialmente importante per dire che
ci sono delle altre mamme le mamme umane
che allevano in gruppo
questi puccinotti ma l'idea bizzarra
qual era quella di può insegnare la
rotta migratoria questa specie perché di
fatto va perso la capacità di migrare
insegniamo a rotta migratoria questa
specie per poter seguire le mamme
surrogate su un ultraleggero a motore
come potete vedere poi in questa
immagine è talmente tanto è forte il
legame che si crea che seguono le mamme
per km
vanno dall austria germania zona fredde
per svernare andare di un sud
dell'italia cup e durata che varia
vf adro betelli in toscana e di serenità
percorrono seguendo le mamme sull'e cat
e sui loro oltre a leggeri fino ad
orbetello basta una sola volta e li
individua in grado di ripercorrere
telegraph loria e diventano individuo
esperto in diritto capace poi a sua
volta di insegnarlo ai giovani pittori
che poi cresceranno quindi l'individuo
in primavera ritorna verso le proprie
aree fredde si riproduce potrà poi
accompagnare gli altri divide non sempre
tutto va bene perché durante una delle
migrazioni un uccello che si chiama
idefix s'è perso è andato verso una
rotta migratoria decisa da solo quindi
andato verso la svizzera è stato
recuperato in auto per essere portato a
orbetello ma non avendo visto la rotta
migratoria idefix cosa fai per una vera
mentre tutti si preparano a tornare
verso l'austria noi ancora mi proprio
giù al caldo perché devo andare al
freddo va al caldo e va in puglia e
resta lì per tutto il tempo mentre gli
altri sono nel nord in
[Applauso]
detto questo c'è un aspetto
particolarmente importante per quanto
riguarda l'apprendimento che il rapporto
madre piccolo rapporto importantissimo e
a seconda della specie quanto più è
lungo e legame tanto più sarà importante
ma perché si possa parlare di cultura
cosa che sembra essere una
caratteristica della specie umana perché
noi abbiamo le tradizioni culturali e
poiché gli studi ci dicono che anche gli
animali hanno le tradizioni culturali
c'è bisogno che l'informazione non venga
più distribuita solo a livello della
popolazione ma venga seguita tra
generazioni e generazioni e mamma e
figlia figlia e nonna e così via
importantissimo da questo punto di vista
è l'aspetto legato alla socialità noi
viviamo in un contesto sociale
gli animali sono spese sociali e le
spese sociali la socialità degli animali
è un pochino diversa noi credo che bene
o male le abbiamo più o meno tutte
possono essere tanti maschi tante
femmine sono maschio possono essere
fashion fusion riusciamo rientrano
all'interno del gruppo
ma la caratteristica fondamentale della
socialità e che ci sono dei
comportamenti che sono fondamentali per
stabilire dei legami devono essere
legali veramente salvezza in questo caso
è evidente
il grooming ha un legame parte un
comportamento molto particolare di
portarsi a vicenda questa è la mamma con
la piccola ma da a volte maccarone molto
contenta di questo spulciare che la va
male fa perché dà anche un pochino
fastidio però sostanzialmente è un
legame è un comportamento che viene
manifestato maschio verso la femmina
femmina verso il maschio subordinato
verso dominante tra le femmine è
importantissimo per creare un rapporto
gli studi ad essi sono chiesti perché
così importante il grooming e che cosa
c'è nell'uomo che possiamo vedere è
possibile come comportamento riscontrato
negli animali i gossip noi spettegoliamo
molto quando siamo con un'altra persona
parliamo spesso di una terza persona che
non è lì presente soprattutto quando
queste persone non si conoscono
se siamo dal parrucchiere e ci
conosciamo poco con la signora che
accanto che sta che avrà perché di
solito si trova un elemento la terza
persona con un momento e ci si parla
sostanzialmente da un punto di vista
adattativo si son chiesti perché il
gossip è così importante perché continua
ad esistere a permanere a destare
all'interno della nostra cultura
sostanzialmente perché ci permette di
avere conoscenze su un individuo che non
c'è ci permette di creare legami quella
che è la sensazione che io nel momento
in cui dico qualcosa di un'altra persona
vedrà da dire si parlò di una terza
persona sostanzialmente sto creando
fintamente o comunque ci sto provando a
creare un legame con la persona che
invece lì in quel momento
altra caratteristica che troviamo nel
mondo animale che ci spiega alcuni
comportamenti della specie umana è
l'asilo in questo caso abbiamo il vero e
proprio asilo definì cotter i i
fenicotteri sono specie gregarie vivono
tutte vivono gli individui tutti quanti
insieme formano nella stagione
riproduttiva alle coppie
contemporaneamente c'è la deposizione
delle uova che è contemporanea e di
conseguenza la schiusa delle uova e
contemporanea per cui abbiamo tanti
pulcini che sono pronti nello stesso
momento
cosa succede che i genitori si dividono
le cure parentali dell'uovo quindi per
arrivare al luogo circa 28 30 giorni
dopodiché per il primo mese di vita di
nuovo i genitori si occupano dei propri
pulcini quindi seguendoli guidandoli
dando loro
mangiare a un certo punto quando i
vicini sono sufficientemente grandi ci
sono degli adulti che si prendono cura
di loro
e questo perché perché i genitori
possono andare a recuperare quelle
energie che hanno investito durante
l'allevamento la schiusa delle uova
durante l'allevamento dei piccoli nel
primo mese di vita questo è importante
perché dà la possibilità ai genitori di
poter poi garantire la sussistenza del
piccolo perché genitori devono poi dar
da mangiare al piccolo quindi è
importantissimo questo aspetto che
riscontriamo nel mondo animale che tanto
è uguale al mondo vanno soprattutto oggi
quando entrambi i genitori sono
costretti a lavorare e quindi fanno le
proprie cose per cui è necessario che
altri si prendono cura dei propri
piccoli
questa è una storia di cui vi racconto
la parte animale e lascio a voi
l'interpretazione umana è la storia di
wolf lupo i lupi hanno questa
caratteristica particolare di essere
animali che definiscono la propria
natura in base al ruolo che hanno
all'interno della struttura gerarchica
ogni lupo sta benissimo cosa fare e il
lupo dominante il maschio alfa è il
leader all'interno del gruppo ma di vera
e propria leadership si parla quindi
viene scelto è il lupo in grado di
guidare l'intero branco e lupo che dà
sicurezza agli animali si muovono
seguendo assolutamente wolf in questo
caso comunque il maschio dominante
dopo 15 anni di conduzione del proprio
branco wolf inizia diventare un pochino
anziano e cosa succede che un individuo
all'interno del del branco
il terzo in scala gerarchica chiede
supporto a un individuo più alto il
rango rispetto a lui ma sempre sotto
wolf e provano ad attaccare wolf wolf
viene attaccato ma nulla perché comunque
lui è il maschio dominante però sente
che il suo ruolo non è più riconosciuto
all'interno della struttura gerarchica
del proprio branco quindi non si sente
più leader wars si lascia andare
wolf perde la vita e il branco pre perde
il proprio leader
e ancora oggi ad un anno di distanza il
branco sta ancora lottando per capire
chi sarà il leader all'interno del
gruppo
lasciavo l'interpretazione perché
nell'ambito politico se noi avessimo il
leader probabilmente non avremo le lotte
di potere che continuare ad esserci ai
giorni nostri
dopo avervi detto avevo illustrato un
pochino quelle che sono le
caratteristiche che riscontriamo nelle
animali che a volte ci danno una
come di lettura per il comportamento
umano c'è una differenza sostanziale tra
noi e gli animali queste sono le
seychelles vedete lo sviluppo antropico
che noi riusciamo comunque a manifestare
continuamente quindi andiamo ad occupare
diverse aree e la caratteristica
fondamentale è che mentre gli animali
preservano gli animali fanno di tutto
per poter conservare la propria specie e
per non vederne una fine l'essere umano
è invece non è in grado di preservare
noi siamo l'unica specie umana oggi
esistente siamo soli 35 mila anni fa
c'erano cinque specie umane che
abitavano il nostro pianeta
certo come ci hanno spiegato potremo
andare su marte potremo andare a
colonizzare l'universo ma quello che
possiamo fare oggi è preservare qui dove
siamo perché è importante per preservare
la nostra specie grazie
[Applauso]